good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight there are a lot of far
away places in this world Namibia for
example but Europe is not one of them
Europe is where your kids spent junior
year abroad Europe is an easy flight
from the east coast of the United States
to pretty much anywhere in the continent
and you know this if you've been on
vacation in Europe as millions of
Americans have for the most part they
speak English in Europe they've got
Starbucks and Taco Bell and air
conditioning in modern hospitals it is
not another world
so given that given how closely related
the United States is to Europe and has
always been you would imagine our
leaders would notice when Europe began
to fall apart especially when the signs
were not subtle at all and they weren't
this summer Germans began clear-cutting
ancient forests to heat their homes in
Poland families queued up for hours to
buy coal just like they did 150 years
ago
in the UK the government projected that
more than 10 000 britons will freeze to
death will die this winter for lack of
heating fuel freeze to death
in England
that is not supposed to happen in a
first world country so Europe is moving
backward at high speed and it's not
clear where it'll end
so the question is why is this happening
and the answer for once is a very simple
one the war in Ukraine that's why it's
happening a huge percentage of Europe's
energy came from Russia those Imports
have now been banned supposedly to
punish Vladimir Putin what's the result
of this punishment well the Russian
Ruble is now far stronger than it was a
year ago the European economy meanwhile
is collapsing
Europeans are much poorer than they were
when the war in Ukraine started so how
is that a victory
for Europe and the west and democracy
well that's a fair question it's an
obvious question but no one in
Washington appears to be asking that
question
instead the by demonstration is doubling
down on the self-destructive mistakes
that are destroying the European Union
the White House banned Russian oil
natural gas and coal was our moral duty
and then at the same time the Biden
Administration crushed domestic oil
production here by canceling oil and gas
leases and then as if that wasn't enough
the bite Administration sold a piece of
our strategic petroleum Reserve maybe
this country's most important resource
to China
none of this hurt Putin in any way all
of it impoverishes the United States
so what could possibly be the
justification for doing that we've
wondered anyone who's paying attention
has had to have wondered that well this
week Congressman Jamie Raskin of
Maryland of Bethesda answered that
question
Russia is an Orthodox Christian country
with traditional social values and for
that reason it must be destroyed no
matter what the cost to us
so this is not a conventional War this
is a Jihad Jamie Raskin said that out
loud but many in Washington agree with
him in both parties they would like to
see World War trans immediately
so what is a Jihad going to mean for you
well
the details are stunning thanks to the
bite administration's religious war in
Ukraine this country is about to run out
of diesel fuel according to data from
the Energy Information Administration by
the Monday of Thanksgiving week that's
25 days from now there will be more no
more diesel
so what's going to happen then well
everything will stop that means trucks
and trains and barges all unable to move
farm equipment will shut down there will
be no deliveries because there will be
no trucks there'll be no diesel
generators and then inevitably our
economy will crash because everything
runs on diesel fuel
not on solar panels not on wind farms on
diesel fuel diesel is not a negotiable
commodity you have to have diesel
so what happens when we don't have it
well yesterday Fox's Jackie Heinrich
apparently alone in the White House
Press Corps asked the White House
spokesman John Kirby that very question
what's the plan here we're running out
of diesel
John Kirby standing at the podium
representing the White House the
president of the United States the
administration the largest organization
in human history the executive branch of
government had no answer
but don't worry he said we will be
exporting plenty of energy to Europe to
help fight that Progressive crusade in
Ukraine watch
what are we doing to increase the supply
of diesel given that the Energy
Information Administration said as of
October 14th the U.S only had about a
25-day supply you have the Northeast and
New York already rationing home heating
oil what are we doing to prepare for the
winter and to ramp up supply of diesel
I'll take the question on the diesel
because I just don't have the the data
on that in front of me so let me take
that and and we'll get back to you on
that but but at large the president has
been working very very hard to make sure
that we're uh that not only are are we
ready for fluctuations that could come
and of course the prices are going down
and we think that's important
but that we are also doing what we can
to help our European friends and
partners who are also going to be facing
a long cold winter we have doubled our
commitment the commitment he made in
March for natural gas exports to Europe
we've doubled that commitment
in terms of actual you know getting
things over there getting natural gas
over there and we are working with with
foreign suppliers of natural gas and oil
to see if we can't help our European
Partners diversify their own storage and
supplies
so just pause and Savor the irony here
just for a moment because now everything
is irony they've been telling you for
decades
since Al Gore left the White House that
the single greatest threat to the world
was warming
and because of their efforts to fight
warming you are in danger of freezing
and unlike warming freezing actually
kills people a lot of people every year
and it will kill people in the west this
year thanks to their efforts to fight
warming okay
the second thing to notice is the White
House spokesman's totally uninterested
blase response
to the most basic question anyone could
ask which is what are we doing about the
fact we're running out of diesel fuel
and he has no idea and he's not
embarrassed that he has no idea
the problem is at this point there may
not be an answer because there may not
be a way to avoid a disaster diesel fuel
is not just low in this country it's low
in every Western nation that has aligned
itself with Ukraine all these nations
preparing for World War Trends are
running out of diesel fuel as New York
Magazine is reported the last time there
was this little supply of diesel there
were about 3.5 billion fewer people on
the planet well that's puts it into
perspective
so the bite Administration responded as
you know earlier this year at a rising
gas prices which they feared above all
because the midterms are coming in two
weeks by tapping the Strategic petroleum
reserves but that will not work here
the Northeast home heating oil Reserve
contains a million barrels of diesel in
case of emergencies the problem is the
demand is so high across the board that
according to the Washington Post even if
the bite Administration used Every
Single Barrel in that stockpile
that stockpile would be empty in less
than six hours
and of course it's not just diesel
that's running out jet fuel is up about
23 percent in just the last month
kerosene which if you don't live in New
York City you know perfectly well it's
used to eat people's homes to keep them
from dying
is now close to seven dollars a gallon
who hosts Heats with Kerosene by the way
poor people eat with kerosene
and they're the ones who can't get it
seven dollars a gallon in New England
people are worried about freezing to
death this winter here's a local Fox
report
West Hartford homeowner Sharona Resnick
Kravitz has been paying for oil to heat
her home for more than 35 years this is
New England it gets cold here or cold
Sharona is a widow living on a fixed
income she says before her husband
passed away they shared the bills now
she is having to make sacrifices how are
you preparing and trying to figure out
what can you sacrifice at this point
um food
I go to the grocery store and I'm very
frugal about what I buy she tells me at
six dollars a gallon buying oil has
become a huge burden the average home
uses 800 gallons of oil per year that's
almost five thousand dollars at the
current rate
this shouldn't be happening in this of
all countries the United States has some
of the Deepest by some measures the
deepest energy reserves on the planet
it's our main strength cheap energy is
the reason this is a rich country
that's the reason
that's why we're exceptional because we
have cheap energy and this country was
energy Independence a few years ago
now if you want to fix the economy you
would make this country energy
independent once again you'd bring back
cheap energy that will fix the economy
quicker than anything else in fact it's
the only thing that'll fix the economy
but the byte Administration for whatever
reason has done the opposite depleting
our strategic petroleum reserve for
example they just released another 15
million barrels the other day
because they know that's running out the
White House is also begging foreign
governments for help in the most
humiliating possible way Biden just went
and begged the Saudis in secret for more
oil as New York Times reported this week
Biden's top aides quote thought they had
struck a secret deal to boost oil
production through the end of the year
but then the Saudi royal family decided
not to go along with it they're not
ramping up their oil production they're
doing the opposite
saudi's oil minister is now telling the
West to brace for energy shortages watch
this
it is my profound Duty
to make it clear to the world
that losing emergency stock
may become painful in the months to come
so an energy shortage is not really a
debate over whether some dude should be
on the girls swim team this is adult
stuff
countries rise and fall on the basis of
what energy costs
and when there's a real energy shortage
Things Fall Apart people die economies
collapse poverty sets in systemic
poverty not just in the bad part of town
but in your part of town so this is a
real thing
the problem is the people running the
government are children
they not only can't admit what they've
done wrong they don't even understand it
here's Karine Jean-Pierre the glass
ceiling shattering spokeswoman at the
White House addressing the question
yesterday
a map just to get your thoughts on this
New York Times report that U.S officials
thought they had a deal with the Saudis
before the president went to Jeddah in
Saudi Arabia for his meeting with the
Crown Prince but they thought they had a
deal on oil supplies and oil uh price of
oil but that the Saudis backed out of
that deal what can you tell us about so
we have been very clear about how we
believe parts of that report was
mischaracterized and there has been some
changes that have been made to that
report look we've also been clear that
our trip that the president's trip to
the Middle East was not about oil gas
prices go down with the Saudis that the
Saudis then backed away from again the
trip was not about oil
this is embarrassing she can't even
conjugate the verb correctly this is the
spokesperson
it's a joke she doesn't know what oil is
and she's lying
they're all like that these people are
not capable of running a country this
big and this complex and that's why it's
falling apart Joe Biden is blaming gas
stations for high prices
how's Kamala Harris responding to all of
this well she's responding to diesel
shortage by telling you Diesel's bad
watch
I have a particular fondness I must tell
you for electric school buses I love
electric school buses on a daily basis
25 million children in our country every
day go to school
on those diesel fueled school buses
and
hundreds thousands of school bus drivers
are driving those buses
which are then these people these
children these adults are inhaling what
is toxic
air
so the lady who never had children is
lecturing you about children the person
who's never had a real job is lecturing
you about energy policy the woman who
told you masks would stop covid is
telling you about diesel fumes and their
effect on your body this is a joke
the truth is these people are bumping
right smack up against reality and
here's the reality we have 25 days to
avert economic catastrophe catastrophe
is what will happen if we run out of
diesel fuel that's more important than
Prosecuting a Jihad in Ukraine it's more
important than World War trans
everything
depends on this
and we've got 25 days to fix it
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight